over the last six months my team and I
been checking out your best love
restaurants from thousands of
nominations tonight the competition
continues with another of your top
culinary favorites Chinese Chinese food
is one of the great conceit of the world
top Chinese chefs use techniques and
flavor combinations that you won't find
in any other cuisines there's a Chinese
restaurant on nearly every High Street
and there's an incredible range from
small family-run outfits the mission
star fine-dining please gather noodle
please thank you very we tend to think
of Chinese food has been all about chow
mein and special fried rice but great
Chinese restaurants so food that's as
sophisticated and complex as anything
you'll find in a posh French restaurant
I've chosen two fantastic restaurants to
battle it out for a place in the
semi-finals tonight from Mayfair in
London it's the crazy country genius of
KY
come on my style of cooking is the new
modern Chinese as a chef we need to
perform on our heart versus the best of
the northwest Blackburn's you and you a
brilliant family-run restaurant let the
food do the talking
earliest memory of food was just cooking
with my father he said oh you can't
reach the cookers so stand on these four
cases to live yourself oh I can only
choose one Chinese restaurant to go
through the semi-finals so they must
prove to me beyond all doubt that they
are the most worthy contender I'm going
to subject both restaurants to three
challenging tests starting with a cont
road of 30 guests all arriving and
ordering at the same time every
restaurants worst nightmare
first they'll sachet into Mayfair to
sample the avant-garde denied on offer a
michelin-starred chi where is he
chef bless you you look like you just
got with a Chinese boy band look at that
hair incredible so what's that I know
you are a superstar pies kitchen is led
by Alex the demanding head chef
he's a perfectionist who runs his
kitchen with a rudder fire to ensure his
sophisticated dishes are spot-on every
time how many salmon and tall you Batmen
Alex hone these skills in some of Asia's
top five-star hotels before being poked
by Kai's ambitious owner bernard the
intention was to change people's
perceptions about Chinese restaurants
they're trying to reinvent Chinese
cuisine and they put a 21st century
twist on it
among Sky's bold and unusual dishes is a
unique liquid version of a lamb shank
that does not look like a lamb shank in
there so is it supposed to be like a
lamb shank soup or yes right yes it's
it's one of those dishes which catches
people out by surprise so a lot of
people absolutely love it and some
people don't like it I just never had a
lunch out like that before no no
actually not and if you got to sell that
today obviously on the menu make sure
the customers understand what it is
before yes I don't disappoint it they
taste delicious she's a really strange
way of executing it I love these guys
they are very very creative and this
food is out there and I just hope that
my diners get it and love the experience
Kai will need to be on top of the game
to survive my ultimate pressure test
two hours two courses yeah I'm gonna be
over everything I'll be in the kitchen
I'll be the dining room and I'll be
watching and listening to everything so
make sure that you give my diners and
experience never to forget normally
bookings are staggered to take the
pressure off the kitchen but not tonight
my 30 diners will push Kai to the edge
and give them a chance to shine